okay welcome to our livestream today we
are in our infinite series of meetings
about language completeness and
consistency and our first item here is
about naming
ionised objects and I guess the issue
here is if I do something like I say
range of 10 or something then I say that
analysts with something else um when I I
can eyes this what is the issue though
the issue is right click I can ization
is that correct right and by the way in
our new UX where the purest selection
you know that that spans selection will
get a raft that Roth will probably
contain an icon eyes option right I know
nothing about
well John yeah yes yeah yeah but that's
a topic that has really been broached ok
but so now the question you have a lot
of other people in this meeting all
right and also let me just so we have
another example if you were to select
the range of 10 and select it then icon
eyes it and you would get you know since
it's not one of the magic ones that has
a dedicated icon you get head of thought
thought thought nice right by the way
what do we do but nonetheless you might
you might still want to name it I
understand I understand that by the way
what do we do what are the other magic
things other do we do we correctly magic
if I like I mean there probably some
other types of things that we could make
magic like for example if I say some
evasive I 820 for example and aya kanai
that oops
yeah that's a bit cruddy him I mean
shouldn't we have some kind of + + +
tight finger I think if we make it easy
to name them then that becomes less of
an issue fair point
have we actually thought through I bet
we've not thought through what other
things might be magic magic like that I
mean there we did have a lesson we
actually shrunk it at the at the last
review with you which was I know six or
nine months ago fair enough ok well
let's talk about naming them ok so what
do we imagine what do we imagine the UX
of naming might be right so one
possibility that occurs to me is there
could be like a little pencil icon that
allows you to you know enter in edit
mode ok we could do that I'll tell you
what we could do that on hava mmm
right we don't want to do that normally
we don't want to see a pencil every time
you see an expression brinjai you do not
want to see a pencil now I mean that's
one possibility or we could have
something here where you just enter a
name that seems weird and I thought I
saw a UX document somewhere that looked
like that where the yeah but I think
that's weird and ok well you would like
to maybe in this state so on hover you
want a pencil is that what you're saying
sure on hover a pencil or oh what's that
for mobile would the thing be like a
long press well the so there's there is
a more fundamental question here which I
don't think we've ever properly answered
which is what happens if you click on it
click on an icon eyes thing and not in
the plus or minus area but just you know
in a you know in the other area
I believe it's currently not selectable
and that's right so so so what one could
imagine so
one could imagine I'm not sure if that's
the right thing but one could imagine
that if you click on it that it's
basically a shortcut to select the
entire icon eyes blob in which case you
know it that would be the same in the
touch world and then in the world of
selection wrasse
then you can throw it into a selection
raft I see you can throw the the update
the in the selection raft you could have
a field where you could type in the name
yeah and so and to clarify for other
folks who don't know what I'm talking
about
is what we're talking about trying to do
on a twelve on a twelve one time frame
is to basically have the ability for a
customizable raft which is effectively
in a patch cell that pops for a given
selection and there are some other
applications that do this sort of thing
right now and they'll do things like you
know you make a selection and out pops
out you know some sort of style widgets
it allows you to fold base and italicize
and change colors that kind of thing but
I'm working on a proposal that would
allow you to just basically you know
customize arrest based on you know based
on what's actually being selected and so
you know we would probably go back and
re implement the triggers for example
for the image editor to be you know a
custom setting for for this option on on
image on images and then similarly we
could have a custom setting you know on
blobs on the blobs here okay we have two
interest
questions on a live stream one question
is could the ionized name be referenced
from an expression well so the question
there is could you given that you have a
named icon in there could you do a
position and find the named icon see
what I'm saying so if I say I can eyes
you know range of 10 comma foo yeah
right and then I've got something where
I have a list of about whatever it is
you know I can say and then I can I say
oh the answer is no because that that
expression needs to evaluate as range of
10 right I can eyes only lives in the
box world right it I mean it's by the
time dollar you know by the time make
expression is done so we have begun to
evaluate there is no icon eyes anymore
right though actually is it in the
current implementation is it even that
far along it might even be the kernel
might not even see it the front end
might never send anything except the
interpretation oh that's true all right
so the answer is no to that correct okay
so it's similar to and I don't know
whether people really do this I mean I'm
noticing the right-click menu doesn't
have a color I mean but that would be
another example of something I just made
two things red yeah that's another
example of something that's never passed
to the kernel right great other way
somebody just sent me an example which I
haven't had a chance to look at yet of a
paper where they have colored variables
and claimed that it's highly useful in
understanding what's going on um okay so
next thing from yeah I mean I mean you
know it in principle it's possible to
you know create a customized notation of
course that is meaningful and
interpretable in some way but it's not
what you get by default
what happens if I say symbol of the
string and then a colored something or
other that's a really good question I
suspect it's gonna fail I suspect you're
going to get some kind of error for
coming back from that yeah it says it
can't be used as a symbol name yeah
Brenda's linear syntax embedded or
something right the first character yeah
yeah the first character will be the
linear syntax escape you know and even
even if even if that worked the case for
the first character the linear syntax
escape probably still as my guess is not
a character that could be used in a
simple day anyway we could make it that
would so that that would look couldn't
we that would be extremely inadvisable
this is is there a comma in there
somewhere
what do you mean I mean if you unform at
that cell right yeah so right so box and
right if you unformatted that cell right
you'll see that there's a there's the
open linear syntax escape and then
there's probably a slash star you know a
boxing you know that doesn't look like a
symbol name and and and and and you
don't want to try it would create all
kinds of chaos okay we try this every
roughly every five to ten years because
um okay but but you know there there is
you know something that can be done
around the kinds of things that are
going on and Jason Harris's notation
package yeah we should you know what we
should have a discussion not here right
now but we should have a discussion
about that at some point can we whose
p.m. and III I don't know if his package
presently supports coloring but the
kinda stuff he's doing certainly could
in principle support it I think we
should figure out in the
in the modern world of function
repositories and Pacolet repositories
and things we should figure out you know
what the future of his package is whose
PMI yeah okay though
so can we get at some point a meeting
set up about that package okay a number
of interesting comments on the
livestream here
okay so Ethan says you'd like the
ability to add his own icon instead of a
text name that is a perfectly reasonable
idea right so I mean if you if you use
the two argument form of icon eyes then
you can you know the second element can
be an arbitrary expression so if you
have your favorite image or so picture
of a tiger exactly the right size maybe
we need to tweak the logics there a bit
yeah well let's think about that logic
for one second let's just think about
that for one second non explicitly sized
images don't we want to do something I
mean don't we want just like we have
auto sizing in various places wouldn't
we want to auto size here let's see what
happens if I if I do something like come
could it be auto size and auto crap so
potentially use some smartness to focus
on like the eyes of the time no let's
not do that
that would be weird having that as a
thumbnail opps okay so that's clearly a
lose but we clearly have to fix that
mm-hmm okay and sorry I'm no longer
looking at the screen but because I do
regular pentagon and normal-sized
graphics right so that needs so you know
it's perfectly reasonable to use one of
the you know the smallest image size
multiplier we could make that work
that's not at all unreal
and fun let's do it I think
to bug yet um yeah yeah if somebody
files it about as a bog week we can fix
it okay okay so in the case where they
are typing you know let's say that we
have this raft type approach do we think
there'll be an input field there or what
to enter the name
or I think that we need an input field
for two reasons one is you might want to
you know restore the default for
whatever reason and so how would you do
that by by deleting the input field
deleting the input field or maybe there
there would be a clear button
okay well I'm yeah I mean when it's in
edit mode we can you know significantly
change the appearance and I think that
would probably be acceptable for most
people okay and so then to get an image
that you just copy paste an image into
the input field sure because you're not
going to have a valuation in that input
field I mean do we want people to type
double quotes to get a string or do we
want this to be a string by default type
of thing I think we want it to be a
string by default if it's not a string
by default and you have issues of you
know spacing and figuring out whether
you want to evaluate the contents not
going to think I prefer just to keep it
a string by default okay fine
so Billy I guess you'll be the one
designing this thing so with the I mean
you you're probably designing the the
the selection raft anyway so there's
just another feature for the selection
raft yeah I'm thinking about the the
hyperlink thing that we had just done as
well as a possible starting point for
how yeah the hyperlink thing finished
but anyway okay we got another some
other comments on the live stream here
um would be nice to add an icon eyes
previous output option to the
suggestions bar that's a reasonable idea
it's sort of related to our nets let's
let's stick a pin in this one because
it's related to our next well maybe you
want it even for a small thing I didn't
know but that elated to our next agenda
item about large outputs and I could
yeah right as the Ethan on the live
stream is mentioning that large outputs
adding micronized to that box will be
useful um let's see although actually
that raises the point that it totally
makes sense that copy output from above
might have some threshold where at
auto-icon aizen's no I don't know how
many people use copy output for above I
okay okay I see much more usage of copy
input from above the copy output from
above but if it's useful as you know the
you know having something as you know
especially if it's easy to undo the icon
do the optimization so having something
that auto I can eyes is something that's
large for you know whatever your
definition of large is that seems useful
it does seem very useful yeah so let's
think about that for a second so so
let's say I have a big output here and
I'm going to do so copy output from
above would do that normally
it that does seem useful - that's a good
idea - Auto ionize that I mean like if
it's bigger than like a quarter of a
page perhaps one could also I can eyes
we could also have it bury into the
output limiter
if the output limiter was produced by
this kernel sorry what do you mean look
so so if you are pre if your output for
above people might not even expect this
to work but if your output from above
was output limited and you do copy
output from above I don't even know what
it does right now probably something
really crazy but no I might write that
in that case it should definitely ionize
yes and and in that case in that case it
might have to go to the kernel type in
eyes but it does seem like the right
thing to do I agree
yeah I like this idea I mean the only
question is whether we should give
people a choice when when they do copy
output from above if it's big say I mean
if we did something where even if it's
longer than a couple of lines it would
say do you want to ionize this I don't
think we and so the you know the the
prediction interface case of course will
show that right to you so if you have
poor jockey and you had predicted her
face turned out you'll be able to see it
and do it but you know good to help to
keep her jockeys do you know um all
right let's see that's a commentary
about rainbow braces of coloring
brackets differently we have a bunch of
stuff coming for nested brackets in 12.1
that we've we about invoke braces
specifically and where we last left it I
I we were looking at other sorts of
concepts for doing
you know for highlighting expressions is
some mouse-over concepts not going to
think rather than doing something like
rainbow brazzers yeah that's right we
needed to come back to those those
should be on parts agenda for user
assistance but after we've got greening
and ghosting working yeah well they are
you know okay fine
okay um our name to be specified ionised
we you can it's just the second argument
i better being able to automatically I
can eyes really long output instead of
using short yeah I mean I think that
there's different look I think what we
need to talk about really is a form of
of I mean look short is from version one
we can do better than this this should
be an icon of some kind you can click
the the shortened form of short right I
mean I don't see any reason why that
can't be an active elements in the
middle there you can just click on to do
things with what do people think about
that issue I think the main issue was
who was tasked implemented and what
tools they had to work with which is to
say Lou was fast to implement it and
there was you know and you know it's
either short or he invents his own short
which is not such a great idea that is
not very wonderful what it does in the
in the pure textual system although what
would you suggest that it could do
better given that I mean in output form
it doesn't have any obligation to be
faithful right but I mean I think an
output form it should just do angle
bracket blah blah blah just like the
short thing doesn't mean if I say short
of you know range of 50 or something
here it's going to produce angle
brackets and that's what I think I can I
should do but containing what
whatever the ionizer said I know what's
it you know I think it should just be
the output form of I can eyes should be
whatever it is you know something like
angle bracket angle breath I mean I'm
thinking something like um angle bracket
angle bracket brace right yes although
that mmm I mean I suppose we could make
this work but right in point of fact
that brace data does not exist in the
kernel right it's just a front-end
resource so okay fair enough
I mean that's something that if there's
a name there we can just stick in
whatever the name is fine okay so that's
another action item there okay can we
come back to the question of short okay
I think we should just revisit it and
try and figure out how we make that be
interactive make sense and I I think and
that way if we did that people could
copy this they could copy the whole
thing so that would become an icon eyes
sequence basically in the middle of that
right and then they could copy the whole
thing and it'll just work well no I mean
the point of short actually short is not
interpretable right I mean it's like I'm
like well but but but at either that the
same idea could happen as happens with
data set where it says do you want to
store this in the notebook or not
because short could be used for two
purposes it could be used for visual
visually shortening it and it could be
used for storage shortening it and to me
those things should be selectable
between maybe I mean I mean one of my
worries is that you know short is used
in a lot of places to sort of limit I
know
so for you know if we suddenly make it
where it's not automatic the default
will be that it limits it but but it
could happen so what one could imagine
some way of using short that you could
rather than you know getting you know
the those literal actually I don't even
know exactly what it is is being
returned right now but you could instead
you know have you know some have the
ability to populate some sort of
template from it hmm yeah so I'm sorry
sorry well let's talk about that too but
John what I'm sorry what did you mean by
to populate a template
can we lose to an ally sorry miss that
kid you're what did you mean by by
population template well so short has
fundamentally certain certain pieces
that you can imagine filling it in
different ways you know and you know I
had the prologue and epilogue
I didn't get what you saying right so
look okay
can we do a little bit of investigation
of short could maybe Lou look at this a
bit and my suggestion is that by default
it does this that it actually shortens
but it has an option to store a notebook
and that
that otherwise you know if you're in the
same session right it can it could have
kernel access right to the to the
information okay now it's shallow
fundamentally different in terms of the
way it should work well shallow is
fundamentally different in the way it
works so short for better for worse
basically makes the boxes and then
shortens them shallow goes into the
expression and actually modifies the
expression and sort of type sets that
shorten that shallowed expression well
the way that that the fact that short
makes the but I mean look I originally
wrote short in the version 1 typesetting
system okay with its output form stuff
and I have no you know I'm sure I wrote
it quite quickly at that time hopefully
it's been you know much revised since
then right so the short so there are in
fact two separate implementations of
short one for output form and one for
the Box world so Tom I think wrote the
Box e1 in C code and you know 95 and
I've I have fixed a couple of bugs but
it's not easy code and somebody has
anybody looked at my code was it still
there it's probably still that it's
probably still there I mean I don't
think lebryk may have done some work in
there also okay yeah I don't think it's
particularly stupid you're right it's
been unmodern eyes for 30 years right so
um okay well alright so action item here
is Lu should take a look at it and see
what he can figure out yeah the comment
I would make about shallow is we had
complaints about expressions and
messages being too big and so we now
automatically use shallow when
generating messages so that they aren't
too big which is great except when you
get the placeholder exactly where the
interesting information in the message
would have been
and because shallow is lossy there's now
no way of seeing of recovering that
information okay what if that was my
entrance oh that was my interest in shot
in bringing shallow up into this
discussion okay but fun the way you're
basically saying is that shallow doesn't
do a good job of finding what's
interesting
right I mean Charlie and I don't think
it can and and looking at the
documentation right now it's based on
depth and so shallow is probably the
wrong function to be doing this I mean
look shallow is a very primitive version
one function okay it's actually a
combination function okay um okay but my
point here is this is another
interesting thing which is actually I'm
going to add this to my list of student
projects is make a maker machine learned
short and shallow you know what I'm
saying so that we we try to figure out
what's the interesting part of an
expression try to figure that out
automatically does that make any sense
right see whether we can do a better job
basically anybody got one two comments
on that is it a stupid idea well I mean
machine learning requires training data
I don't know how your necessary if it's
unsupervised who knows um the other
thing is if it's a if it's a stack trace
from j-link then you actually just want
the whole thing okay but I mean look the
basic question is is there a is there a
generic smarter way to do this code
messages have controls in them that
determine what kind of you know what
kind of thing like that to do okay so so
basically right there there's dollar
message P print and so what Jeremy the
describing is to the behavior of the
default value automatic now if you want
to you know you can in principle write
your own done right that's a big pain is
there any UX way of rerunning with
dollar message preprint i mean in other
words if we find that a message in the
message controller okay so let me
generate okay hold on a second let's do
something like um
don't know what this is gonna do is this
counter it's this kind of list if I I
don't know let me put a different term
how do i generate I just want generate a
message with a long thing in it blah um
that was a bad idea okay come on how can
I do this um help I'm not entirely sure
what you're trying to do I'm trying to
generate a message with okay there we go
here we go this is a message with with
which has been shortened right okay so
here we should have something else in
there that says something about reset I
don't know exactly what but something
about just like we have turn off this
message turn off output sighs limiting
and maybe you should be able to do that
for this message did you get what I'm
saying yeah I'm not sure we have the
control love you know to fine-grained
control to actually turn it off for a
specific message but well fair enough
but I mean for initially we could just
have if it notices that it's got output
limiting in it then it could say turn
off output limiting mm-hmm that seems
useful to me comments from other people
since you're a consumer of this yeah my
hesitation is that I actually turned
that off that menu that you're showing
because the stack trace is always
truncated to remove anything interesting
from it and it also tends to hang things
and when you try to abort computations
that are spewing messages you end up
aborting the mmm that that basically say
okay fine you're saying that it doesn't
work as well as it should so why don't
we try and figure out how to fix it
mm-hmm rather than you simply switching
it off and what's this show full
expression this is a short that
effectively already has so if you are
right so if you click on it then yeah
okay so this is a version of short that
we've already built that could be put
into the main system couldn't it let's
explore that okay that's can we explore
what this is and whether it could be
used here and let's go on to the okay so
I agree with John Maclean's point here
that this is a bad example
okay range of a thousand I think I'm
here to do ten thousand or ten thousand
right so there right so you so that a
think has the whole I think that has a
reference to everything and it so if you
were to do copy output and you know
stick that into I think that'll evaluate
it has a reference to out of 16 right so
in this kernel session out of 16 right
but there you know so there are two
parts Lewis Lewis here so lucrative
spoken up in this old discussion about I
would have if I had things to offer yes
okay fine I mean yeah
right so there are two possible actions
one is you know embed the whole thing
and I can eyes it or you know keep this
view and store it maybe that's not very
useful hold on Brian our live stream
makes the very obvious point how about
ionizing the message in other words if
we had put if these things were icon
eise's rather than no no no because if
you have a yeah it's got actually
shortened within memory right right
because if you have you know an enormous
you know scarce array or something
could it be presented in some sort of
shorter form though where it's just a
dread message short no problem is this
the problem is that look by the time
you've got messages spewing out
something has gone wrong and the thing
that's gone wrong might be generating a
gigabyte of crud right and you don't
want that gigabyte of cut to even exist
in your in your system it's it's
actually got to really remove it and
truncate it it's not good enough to just
visually truncate it okay let's go back
to this though so I mean this particular
motif of this circular thing which I
quite like it's probably the future of
what we should be doing visually for
this for this some short thing and I
think what we should be doing is when
you click it just like in the case of
the messages when you click this that
should be able to get more here but now
this question of whether it stores on
the notebook I don't see why we
shouldn't put um you know that I mean to
what extent is an output limit are
always the complete output so it's so as
it currently exists it's never the
complete output it has unless you do I
guess show all because what it is it
didn't oh now you I misspoke I miss
explain my question okay is the is the
full value of out n I'm by the whoever's
making back on I was good but sorry
please the UM
the you know is the full output you know
full value of out n and output limiter
or can an output limiter be a sub part
of the value of out of an then a limiter
I think is always well at least as
currently implemented it's it's out of
sixteen okay so it contains it contains
a reference out of sixteen which is why
you know enough seventeen worked because
even though the boxes which are visible
don't contain though you know you know
there's a reference that out of sixteen
and this will get better when we have
percent modernization well where it's no
longer just out of sixteen but there's
some underlying UUID and so on maybe so
okay so anyway look the main suggestion
is to have something which is one of
those little boxes that says store a
notebook somewhere here is that correct
yes or something like that yes and
possibly a store and I can eyes button
so I don't know if those are two
distinct buttons or we always want to
store an icon eyes since do we like the
visual from this okay I think it's okay
to and I think we should definitely try
to imagine if we wanted maybe a small
icon but I wouldn't I wouldn't mess with
it too much
okay fine but but you understand that we
that we want two things here so there's
the store in notebook question like if I
say I mean if I do this I will make it
the thing at the bottom that was decided
to datasets yeah hello computer Wow it
didn't get it in that case well normally
it would have that would not be stored
in a notebook right unless this always
doesn't this is still doing this social
could you please track this down this is
really really dumb this is not supposed
to be storing in any kind of user
document directory this is supposed to
be in the local object store as I've
said like
five times I know there's so that still
that's a separate discussion
that was that that Stephen there's a
whole discussion to be had there which
is on the agenda okay
not today but all right okay well so
long as it's on the agenda I'm happy
okay but anyway this didn't get its
usual I'm not in the know I'm I'm not
sure I do actually use that but Sparsit
it is okay so that's the thing right and
and there's a if you open up the data
set example in the agenda I mean sort of
sort of one of my concerns is oh that's
interesting okay that did not work I
don't know if you need to open this in
the prototype build or who knows very
much what were you going to point out
well it's a little bit hard to point out
I look at your screen alright let's do
that is there is there that's the wrong
meeting oh I see well then let's make
sure I'm sorry I wasn't expecting to
meet Rick why don't you why don't we go
back to my screen and then I can try to
send screen
yeah we here I can do right now you see
the so we were talking about putting
ionizer store in output in the output
limiter why not put it in the suggestion
bar or because these obnoxious people
switch off the beautiful suggestions
pause so here's my point so it the the
store Now button was designed to look
very nicely with you know summary boxes
as it exists in what ok so there's
something wrong and but we know how it
looks with summary boxes yes when it's
attached the data said it's this bizarre
floaty detached thing and having we
talked about having it go on the bottom
and then to the right this has all been
redesigned at I this is all it's not
redesigned the the thing actually just
the data not your network is just going
to be in the bottom is going to be
floating so horizontal bars to consider
at the bottom as well as a minute so the
design has changed so guys please let me
send your screen a couple of screenshots
ok we've got some great background
noises that sounded like a pig let's see
whether we can get through there any
other palma handles come on please could
you put yourself on mute if you're
making a
okay um
what you go back send me something or
what what was the next point was I
wasn't sure if you were going to be
reusing this literal button and I mean
what I saw dad these all look sort of
weird weird and so I'm wondering if we
need well if we just need one button per
context or if we need to somehow rethink
how we want
well this button happily here ticket
so again I think for the image on the
left its high I think some sort of
responsive ticket so that way when it's
maybe smaller if we could deal with that
but like you were saying Steven I think
I don't I don't know if we would fit in
there but it would fit you know at the
bottom if you want it but would you want
it do that or no that's my let's have it
let's have it merge with this design
yeah right so it makes exactly what it
should say cuz that's a lot of words
that I think you got to play around the
design because I think that this again
these may be more that these may have
more space than they need because we
probably did it that way because we
wanted to fill the bottom of this thing
otherwise everything will be crunched up
on the left yes work on that so you'll
be able to say show : less more all mmm
I'm saying mm-hmm
so Lou are those front-end resources or
those texts is that text in there that's
just highlighting or you're not
resources the style changes are name
styles okay so as long as it's text we
can get that okay so I think that's what
I would do is show more or less etc and
then put that in there try to avoid
having too many words and and probably
don't have it in the you know how don't
have it in the bold font like these are
and I think set size limit can go at the
end or yes be replaced cuz that's I
think it'd just be a gear menu where
doesn't it just look like a gear oh yeah
it's kind of a silly thing to show it
there I mean so we just say show : less
more all and no and no hi can I use or
in store now yeah I think we want the
store now data not notebooks store now
and what would I can eyes do it would
just turn the whole thing into an icon
no one
so I mean if we can fit it in why don't
we have that in that right I think it
would I think it would you know try to
dereference the right actually grab the
full result and I can eyes that's what I
think too which means it goes with store
now because that is a version of store
now
and I can I use the default label it
wouldn't incorporate the short as the
label no it would not but but notice
that the icon eyes version is a stored
version yes that has the yes correct
not a reference to out of something
right the actual
so really what it is it store now in
this form and turn it into an icon which
will be stored so I think Billy you need
to try and come up with some designs
that try to make that clear like perhaps
we again store now : it current form as
icon I think storing is not receive the
icon eyes is going to be what happens
when you push the button again first or
now down there for the sparse array it
goes away and it gets replaced with the
actual underlying expression when it
works yes correct
what do you mean when it works well if
you work in this kernel session right if
you quit the kernel so it there's no
longer a way to find what the original
data was it's well tell you well you've
restarted the kernel I can't do anything
right so that so that probably is a
thing we'll need that state for the for
the output limiters right because an
output limiter if you tried to do what
what happens if you say show all to an
output limiter when you've killed the
colonel you'll get a message saying this
isn't the same kernel session that
generated this output now of course we
could show that automatically I mean you
know the front end certainly has this
information it's how it this is not a
labels yeah so this honestly that this
is um okay so look that's not the right
thing because I mean we do show that in
a much better way if I do this again
here right this will say Daisy not a
notebook store now but if I now do a
quit then that will change what it says
right does it do it dynamically
no but what John is saying is that it
could yeah so that it should not be
offering the store now option here it
should just say you're out of luck right
right
I agree okay so that's another state
that that needs to have what should it
say if you try clicking on it now it'll
go into that state when you click on it
I think I mean another possibility is
that just the button goes away once I
don't know how practical that is but you
know well either the button goes yeah I
mean okay it's start in the earth and in
that state when the kernel gets dropped
or have an unscored state for objects
that are in the notebook like summary
boxes or this output large output on top
like a transparency thing where it's
like obviously not in the notebook I
think it would be nice to have something
III think what do you mean of
transparency thing
some some style change I would leave it
open to that it doesn't to be
transparency but some style change
whether it's a border color or right so
I mean there is a difference
notice how the head is somewhat gray yes
where if you were to reevaluate - and
you sell ya the input and then click you
see it's gray but once you click on the
store now it will turn solid which is
pretty subtle right I mean that that was
the original original implementation
which we kept this just another visual
cue and to maintain but right one of the
reasons why we added the button right so
if you do sparse array of one to three
and it's automatically stored then
you'll you know you never see the button
and it'll be right yeah so so the way
you tell whether the data was stored was
do you see the button or not
sure yep you don't see the button you
don't worry about it
everything's look good it's all stored
so the case that we know that is the
unstirred case where what you see so I
think we do need an indication of that
um you know I think that better rather
than having a line underneath which is
just saying you know it's reminiscent of
my favorite story of you've lost your
last chance to garbage collect um which
is like so what you know so what do you
do now I think it'd be better to just
have a third line here which says data
not stored
underlying data not available not store
underlying data not stored parentheses
underlying data not stored for here and
would it go here as well
where's um yes I think so
same same thing basically but it would
be it will be a parenthetical
I'm not suggesting that's an addendum
there what I'm suggesting that it's part
of the summary box not a not sort of a
raft like thing underneath the summary
box because I think in the case where
there is no action you can take having a
raft is kind of annoying mm okay that's
my suggestion let's let's try that for
this I think we've got a plan for what
to do and then we're also going to look
at the short business and see whether we
can modernize that okay Kant's from
Ethan on the live stream there's no way
to monitor anything in the console
textual progress bars
um yeah we're we're aware of this and
that this is the very next topic on the
agenda its progress bars long output in
the console quickly becomes oh in the
console you mean in the I see what you
mean in in the pure
and here I have no idea what this is
going to do well it's kind of nice that
does anything
wow I didn't know that worked at all
that's a good question for Sushma for
your well one of our requirements is
going to be that it does something for
the unified progress indicators that it
does something sensible and a standalone
kernel right and the question is kind of
used the cusses library and actually try
and do term cap if count cap still a
thing not so much it's probably still
around as a compatibility layer but
basically term info is you know
eventually one and okay okay right okay
well anyway this doesn't look so
horrifying yes I mean although you might
prefer this to be an overwrite type
thing I'm actually impressed that this
works at all um how do I stop it though
oh wow
does that work yep well I mean now with
a new wall from engine maybe more people
will be doing this command line stuff
icon we're back 30 years ha from this to
it but we did some kind of catch a
border or something there to be able to
print that message oh yeah
well amazing okay all right let's go on
progress indicator question right so so
that train and is it classified I think
they absolutely need to leave all this
man I mean this panel is super useful
okay which may mean it's not part of the
unification in the first round of
unification fine okay just right but I
think that the visual look of that
particular bar going across should be
you know brought into alignment with the
visual look of other other progress
indicators okay under no circumstances
remove these I mean you know what we
would want to do is for some functions
that can have super fancy training
progress indicators we should
move towards this type of thing for the
head okay looks like we have a couple of
simple ones to do so let's try that
famous last words
I yeah I agree that this one is pretty
easy and I actually and I agree with
Constantine who proposed this and should
be on in the zoom with us don't see him
so maybe let's just see an absentee or
whether we can yeah call on the
livestream he's asking to the progress
center care to work in the command line
and temperature and the answer is we're
trying to that's we're trying to make
sure that it does presumably using a
term Mpho type mechanism is that correct
we had not gone that far in part because
you know and you know there is an issue
that you know we're not necessarily
guaranteed to have that available but
can you tell if you do have it in in
principle yes whether it's currently
exposed to the language I don't is that
is something I need to investigate but
in principle we do know whether or not
it's available and you know I don't know
yeah and I guess I'd have to talk to
John or Ian at some point about the
windows terminal because well not the
new windows terminal but you know
command.com terminal and what
capabilities it has and how we talk to
them okay but okay all right so what
this is you hear the the it's about the
documentation of override target which
is documented to be automatic and it has
values documented to have true/false and
automatic but what the implementation
actually is is it's false unless you
explicitly set it to true and it's not
obvious you can ever have you know what
would automatically n-- other than one
of true or false so the suggestion was
that maybe we just simplify this and say
default value is false and you can set
it to true way met I would have thought
automatic means oh I see there's no
notion of the overwrite only comes into
effect if there is a thing to overwrite
correct well I can imagine some thing
which looks at permissions in some way
to decide whether I believe I mean well
okay this is made adventure over right
but fails quietly instead of noisily or
something yes for instance or
alternatively fanciful a this is
fanciful I mean in a world of
authentication options I can imagine
something which this is a bit fanciful
you know because what you end up doing
with you know you know pseudo Joan etc
right mm-hmm
one could imagine that that you could
provide the authentication information
to do the pseudo Joan which would be
like really really overwrite this
mmm-hmm even though the natural thing
that you would do would not successfully
overwrite any comments about that I mean
I look what what you're saying here it
makes perfect sense to me
as far as it goes I don't think we
should forever kill the possibility that
automatic might do something different
Acey so so you think we should keep the
default value add automatic no I'm
perfectly happy to have the default
value be false okay I think I just think
we shouldn't kill okay um yeah actually
couple interesting comments on the live
stream here about modular progress
indicators where the progress bar is
common but packages can add domain
specific info like net train that is not
a bad idea to have this to have the top
of this be generic and then having this
be an attached panel that you can then
close do you see what I'm saying
right right and certainly I mean
internally what we would do so the
question is how to expose that to the
user right we're not going right we're
going to write some central function and
then have all the different progress
indicator functions calling sure do that
so we probably need some user expose
about progress indicator anyway so we
might as well think about that design
because users are going to want these
things as well so I mean so I think
that's suggestion visually that's will
be a good way of tying this together
Billy did you understand that thought
yeah I'm trying to think of it how how
connects those blue ones that we just
recently redone or be also thinking
about maybe connecting the blue ones and
maybe restyling
to look a little bit closer to this and
then having all that be connected I
think the blue ones are okay I'm just
saying that what we would do here is
this part at the top would be sort of a
blue indicator and then this would be an
extruded piece that is the full panel
with the panel having a close button on
it okay sort of maybe similar to
something that's in the audio I guess
I'm just trying to line it up with other
things that we have so that way well I
know I know I know I don't know whether
it's similar to that but yes it might be
like that to have that but but you know
again this is a progress bar and then
it's got some indicator to show
something could be opened and this one
will be open by default but you might
choose to close it isn't I only tie this
together I mean I think these things
look pretty good but they could be
tweaked and suddenly the top seems a bit
overbearing where it says training
progress you know it kind of also
reminds me of the new info saying said
just yeah I just came yes so I mean look
we've got several metaphors here we've
got these we've got the info connectors
Heidi right so let's pull those together
um okay all right last but not least
should sphere points have Center radius
and theta 5 specs
well definitely centrum radius surely
makes sense um
you
yeah I can't see why we wouldn't want to
do that
polyhedron in a polyhedron like a
uniform polyhedron for example um you
know does it does it frustrate other
people that it's so hard to guarantee
that you're getting a new documentation
window well that's not so hard actually
um
you
you
I see so that goes that's the initial
that's a prefix of R Theta Phi yeah make
sense to me
and right of course that doesn't make
any sense for us fear well I guess
you're rotating the point distribution
yeah I accept that that's kind of a
goofy thing to do and I wouldn't think
that that was a if I say five comma um
why doesn't the sort of complete please
file a bug did you see that yes oh for
goodness sake well I'm assuming that's
correct in terms of their okay this is a
bit miss documented right it should show
the our case and I it really should show
what's in the dot dot dot I think it
should say spec or something there
because otherwise it's very unclear what
the dot dot means but it should show the
our case as well as the R theta v case
okay in this case I would think the R is
useful and the XYZ would be useful as
well right so and what does circle
points do I think it has I think it has
a spec for yeah it has no XY r and theta
and I don't remember exactly how they're
grouped it's exact same thing yeah so
it's this should this is just an
oversight it should do the same thing I
think the only thing about Theta Phi
here which is a little weird is the fact
that you know this is not the unique
case and one could imagine a different
method option and stuff like that
am I making sense yeah I mean cause a
you've been very quiet and and this is
your baby so yeah so sphere points would
be the same I agree but I think we'd
need the three angles because this is
about rotating the frame
so it's three not two no what do you
mean three as opposed to you you say
it's not just our fate if I something
else yes it's because we can't use two
angles to the side where the first point
goes and then we still have a rotation
about that axis it's minor thing hold on
hold on hold on I don't understand that
so you take this rigid object and you
are tipping the earth in some direction
yep why doesn't that just need two
angles because there's another no no go
ahead which is on the x-axis say oh I
understand there isn't the North Pole
the basic point is there isn't the North
Pole yeah so you have to still determine
something else right so basically the
two angles give you what is your new
North Pole for example and then the
third one how much to rotate around that
one so it's like three Euler angles but
these angles are pretty meaningless in
the in the case of a two hundred points
fear the angles are meaningless anyway
yeah I tend to think we should skip the
angles because I think the angles
suggest that there's a precision to this
that there really isn't but the the
translation and the and the dilation
does seem to make sense to me okay one
last comment on live stream here from
Ethan please add a separate dedicated
kernel for documentation notebooks so
you can try things out while your other
notebook is running
interesting I mean we have a
proliferation of service kernels so that
probably going to happen well so we at
one point in time I had tried to put it
on the system kernel which is the
principle in use by the front-end and we
ended up back in to change out four
reasons but I think those reasons have
been dealt with and we probably should
put it back on the system kernel or at
least I can check to see if there are
any other blockages what does that do
well so the system kernel is the kernel
which is dedicated for use by the
front-end it does not use a license
process slot and because it's only used
by us and we're very careful about how
we use it it's guaranteed high
availability but that doesn't seem like
a good thing for the documentation
because somebody will just go and start
doing all that computations in the
documentation and confuse everything and
then they blocked Oh for evaluating
examples
oh no it's sorry I was thinking of
running the documentation browser for
evaluating examples I mean there's an
advantage to being able to have
communication with the rest of your
session from the examples right I mean
so I can I mean one workaround for this
because is the the the the help browser
always uses the kernel marked local so
that the front end browser and the front
end kernel evaluating those examples are
in sync so one way to deal with this is
to make you know create a second kernel
which is identical to local but has a
different name and make that one your
default kernel and then the kernel and
the help center will be the one named
current local and so I mean you either
want communication or you don't want
communication and well the other issue
is that you know this Colonel would use
a license slot on your machine you may
find that desirable because you're not
using it for anything else or you may
find it not desirable because you do
have plans for that license slot right
right right
okay hey listen I don't think this is I
think this is not a an obvious place to
go I mean this question of whether you
can run something you know the way you
can run the documentation maybe this is
a silly suggestion it's just starting
you can you do that just start
essentially a ties point is that it's
not too difficult to define a new local
Colonel understand yeah well that's an
interesting thing
maybe we should and then you could set
it as a no post colonel in the healthy
or I understood yeah maybe we should
make this a bit easier okay let's put
that on another agenda okay um okay
Sushma yes okay one last point which I
just have to make after all my
excitement about the fact that the cloud
is working so well I really want to push
my idea about corresponding file systems
nice I saw your email okay so I think
it's a little weird because of this
notion of having to kind of pin a top
directory and it's you know but it isn't
that weird I mean that's just that's
like what Dropbox has to do as well yeah
sinks the entire directory I understand
that but for me this would be super
super useful like like I would pin you
know I have a directory structure but
I'm trying to publish things and I'm you
know I might publish 500 files and I
don't want to have to have a parallel
door you must have a thousand files in
your directory and which ones did you
publish in which ones didn't you publish
I'm okay with that I'm okay with that
that's okay I don't need to know which
ones I publish because publishing the
typical thing that I'm doing is you know
worst case is I republish it see what
I'm saying because it
overwrites it silently overwrites the
worst case is that I just go through and
publish it again and that's not that big
a deal well I mean I can think of some
other worst cases you think you've
published it but you haven't you think
you've published it but you haven't
published the most up-to-date version I
understand I understand so those are all
things where look we don't have a full
syncing Dropbox type system but in the
absence of that this is a pretty good
second tier because you know that the
main point is to keep the global file
organization and not have to build a new
shadow file organization in the cloud
because you know look sometime in the
future we might have a full
synchronization system but you know what
this I was really excited by this idea
because I think it gives one some of the
benefits of synchronization without
having to build all of that stuff and
it's rather straightforward I mean it
would just be you know you decide on a
sticky base URL that by the way I think
it's a mistake that the base URL when
you publish is always published in your
cloud I think that should be a default
but it should not be the only possible
base URL in the cloud ok and then if
you've got that base URL then by default
this thing would you would define a base
URL in your desktop and then by default
this thing would find you know would
would do the corresponding would do the
correspondence just like mount points I
really like this idea really really like
this idea um okay so we'll talk about it
again I suppose in the user assistance
and/or cloud meeting but I would really
appreciate if somebody would have a try
and have a think through maybe the UX
folks could try and have a think through
how this would work everybody understand
this idea at least well I mean I I
certainly understand the idea my my
concern is just around the the fid
leanness of establishing what what the
route is on your local system and I
understand yeah I understand that's the
I agree that that's a bit fiddly I agree
that's fiddly but I think that the
I agree that's fiddly um how does it
work when you set up a Dropbox mount
point well it so in that case of course
Dropbox is creating its own directory
and you know most people never change
that
I say it's a directory on your machine
on your local machine but moreover
inside your user home directory well
fine so maybe we should do the same
thing maybe one of our options here
should be store well okay you can either
by default we can give you a directory
or you can map to some directory of your
own like your home directory I mean is
it obviously stupid to have it mapped to
it to have it by default be your home
directory I know I mean it could be you
know it it could be like your documents
directory which is the default location
where you know notebooks get saved and
then you change that if you don't like
it and if you say something outside your
documents directory then it just does
nothing in terms of trying to establish
a you know a sub location what do you
mean by that well so I mean if you know
if it's relative inside your documents
directory it's obvious but if it's
outside your document structure you
can't map that to the clouds so don't
try oh I see what you're saying I see I
understand what you're saying then just
stick it in some default publish
directory in the cloud look let's call
is some thought that has to go into this
but let's do it because this is really
there's gonna save us you know as we've
all agreed doing a full synchronization
thing is unbelievably hard and that this
will get us a significant I don't know
70% of the benefit or something vastly
more cheaply
mm-hmm all right okay well thanks
everybody and tomorrow is the exciting
Wolfman gene launch so let's hope that
goes well all right um okay thank you
all thank you to the folks on the
livestream they were very useful cons
today much appreciated
talk to y'all soon